hidey-ho reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we're gonna watch a video
game trailer some Peggy 18 this came out
August the 2018 it's called the sinking
city death may die cinematic trailer ps4
edition I don't know anything about one
of our topper war tears at our patreon
pages whatever video you request we must
do and put up on youtubes whether that
is a review podcast or a reaction this
one's a reaction comes from our good
friend Rohit Banerjee I'm making an
extra effort to make sure I say her name
correctly buddy he had a little
description of it because a lot of times
if I haven't played the game or heard of
it and this game doesn't come out so
June of later this year he said this is
another game which has been scheduled to
released this year but let's see what it
actually comes out I came it's always
getting delayed the thing about this
game is it falls under the horror
mystery genre which kind of falls closer
to Resident Evil and many other similar
games it's a pretty common theme in the
gaming world but person want to see this
style okay he's all about style he has
his own channel as you go check it out
and television more often - it's one of
my favorite genre in any form of content
and something I would like to make
myself in the future in recent memory
only stranger things is a show which
kind of follows this genre close if you
can think of something else do let me
know I will and I won't but I'll think
of some and keep them to myself so I'm
selfish baby 18
definitely some HP Lovecraft line
I heard this game is after-effects of
the flood and I believe he's a private
investigator interest the tommy gun
whoa whoa I see I said stranger things
like the upside down oh damn that
Cthulhu devil reef this guy's having a
terrible day
Devil May reef
wonderful Oh spider what the Gunny has I
love all this tentacular
[Music]
No
then him again ah loop it's purgatory
he's living a predatory guys he is
angered the Elder Gods whoa
interesting can I get some bioshock
vibes yeah I was gonna say that yeah
yeah I wonder if this is gonna be the
kind of game where you like go through
the same environment you've loops but
every time it's a little different or
something like oh that's cool no T's one
level this whole time yeah different
every time it never shifts never changed
on a time period this takes place in
because the aesthetic of his clothing
even the places he's walking through I
think this is like a New England if I'm
not mistaken okay you know like the
clothes and that kind of gun he has to
feel from an older time period yeah and
I like that what you do like oh yeah we
do some like horror sci-fi thing with a
different kind of decor yeah with it
well that fits with all these HP
Lovecraft vibes yes like there's
definitely that all over this yeah I
feel like this is cool for a videogame
especially because I know they're vinick
some like film adaptations of his work
or at least that are heavily inspired by
his work but it also is hard work to
translate so I feel like a videogame is
a place where you might be able to
explore those themes in a visually
interactive place and a kind of
satisfying way my one nitpick criticism
is I wish they would start making Maine
male protagonists look rugged a little
bit handsome good haircut looks like
skinnier and a little bit longer
features like a more pointed nose look
like the related so that one little nip
think of it Curtis
that's where he's like baby make image
it's a different ethnicity or something
let's see if that guy survived this kind
of yeah the other designs in here look
great and this does feel feels like
hauntingly confusing better HP Lovecraft
II yeah it was like poetic yeah poetic
and like there's a hint of madness
underneath it all I'm jaundice shots
like that like the octopus had to go
like creature yeah climbing up towards
him as he's trying to swim to the
surface that was an unexpected effect
because I heard this had to deal with
some type of flood and he's kind of
investigating the flood then I see this
imagery I'm like this is not all what I
anticipated for it yeah but that idea of
like with the flood the water is all
above the sky then it comes crashing
down and it does look like he's in some
kind of weird loop does a good job at
building the mystery here yeah what is
going on exactly am i I get vibes it
like some other video games here or
there it seems like it really is doing
its own thing as well yeah totally i guy
I mean I get what low hit is saying here
because this is an aesthetic that I very
much enjoy as well and I do think that
like there are there are movies and
shows that go shades of here but yeah
it's not what you see all the time
because it does look very surreal it
does look very quiet in its own way but
also very unsettling in science fictiony
while it's being a period piece and all
that stuff i hear it's like an open
investigation kind of world we're doing
like detective mystery stuff and a lot
of that will determine the whale game
yeah
which sounds really cool to me it's just
when you're dealing with something that
has a world like this I'm wondering how
difficult tonight to play through this
case time like it could be a little
complicated on how to properly get down
yeah and then I wonder what the gameplay
mechanics themselves are gonna be like
because I can see this potentially
becoming sort of like a Silent Hill
thing where a lot of what you're doing
is going around you're investigating
you're solving puzzles or you know
arranging things and then occasionally
you will be attacked by some kind of
nightmare creature or something which is
also a video game nightmare creatures
from way back in the day
HP Lovecraft stop monsters like you know
I mean I don't know that Lulu itself is
going to appear beyond that little token
but you know all those tentacle
creatures definitely like whoa miss or
something yeah yeah
definitely got those vibes in it too and
and yell like the spider creatures and
stuff yeah seems to be a point from a
lot you know I got some inception vibes
in this visual aesthetic especially with
things being all upside down yeah he
said stranger things located no I
totally that's very much in here too
it's kind of funny to me with this kind
of world where I'm not sure what's
actually physically tangible here huh
and he has a tommy gun and he's shooting
a creature and I'm like is he actually
like harming this creature with bullets
you know or some spiritual thing we're
watching cuz it takes him away he sees
his version of himself and he gets
thrown back into the loop and also a
little bit of like I haven't played the
game yet deaths ranting I get some
deaths ranting vibes here too definitely
has that's what is happening surreal
body especially when he's got the gill
eyes or whatever there's like a body
horror element there too it's Waterworld
we're watching the prequel the
Waterworld this is Kevin Costner
character yeah yeah yeah which I mean
speaking of fish and all various things
I mean the anime good graphics are all
over the place now but I was very much
caught up in just how beautiful like the
bricks and the water and all that stuff
looked in this and even it has facial
features like it really looks very photo
real and the mood of it too I love the
haunting melancholic kind of tone poem I
have that phrase I'm hearing all the
time now tossed everywhere yeah a
videogame tone poem would be fascinating
that's what we're kind of in store for
here actually yeah well this looks
really cool thanks lo hey guys did you
go check out his channel it's called
another view and we did a reactionary
short film retreat which was a great
horror short film this guy and I talked
an awful lot back and forth ease and
Canada and I'll tell you what guys he's
gonna be someone who's gonna be a very
successful film maker one day but dude
if you want to make it big in film you
gotta leave your country and you got a
move from Canada to Ohio that's where
it's all happening man that's where the
main filmmaking action is at they
or Utah good one of those two states
dude I'm telling you you're gonna be set
for life that's where we make the
connects that's where you get all the
people who are passionate and driven and
want to make films so move there Utah
Missouri
oh yeah Montana Montana both rotas South
South and North Dakota great I would
avoid places like California I would
avoid New York City yeah maybe
Connecticut though that'd be a good one
to go to as well or the Dominican
Republic outlying territory a lot of
people forget the Dominican Republic is
actually in America Georgia's in Florida
I thought it was in Dominica you know
you learn a little bit new every single
day well that's what you're here for
guys and that's where the film industry
you guys can subscribe to the reject
nation click that notification Vallon
tell us what do you think of this
trailer